Thank you for listening to The Rest is History. For weekly bonus episodes, ad-free listening, early access to series, and membership of our much-loved chat community, go to therestishistory.com and join the club. That is the restishistory.com. Interior Chinatown is an all-new series based on the best-selling novel by Charles Yu about a struggling Asian actor who gets a bigger part than he expected when he witnesses a crime in Chinatown. Now streaming only on Disney Plus. The epic return of Yellowstone is now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus. You destroy me, you destroy yourself. Unlike you, I keep my promises. The wait is over. Yellowstone, new episodes now streaming exclusively on Paramount Plus.
感谢收听《历史的余烬》。想要收听每周的独家加更节目、无广告内容、抢先体验系列节目并加入我们备受喜爱的聊天社区吗？请访问 therestishistory.com 并加入俱乐部。网址是 therestishistory.com。《唐人街内情》（Interior Chinatown）是一部全新的系列剧，改编自查尔斯·于（Charles Yu）的畅销小说，讲述了一位苦苦挣扎的亚裔演员在唐人街目睹了一起犯罪后，意外得到了一个比预期更大的角色。目前正在 Disney Plus 独家热播。《黄石》（Yellowstone）史诗般的回归，现正于 Paramount Plus 独家热播。你毁灭了我，也就毁灭了你自己。不同于你，我向来一诺千金。等待已经结束。《黄石》全新剧集，现正于 Paramount Plus 独家热播。
Ooh, Sunwing launched their Black Friday deals early. Nah, you gotta wait until the last day. That's when the real deals drop. I beg to differ. I'm a Sunwing financial advisor. You want more from your vacation, right? That's easy. Book a Sunwing vacation. With these Black Friday deals, you'll be beachin' in no time. Hmm. Actually, these Sunwing Black Friday deals make so much financial sense. Book with your local travel advisor or at... Sunwing.ca Nelson glanced up at the sky. In the east, black clouds were gathering.
哦，Sunwing 提前推出了“黑色星期五”优惠活动。才不，你得等到最后一天。那才是真正的优惠推出的时候。恕我难苟同。我是 Sunwing 的财务顾问。你希望假期能物超所值，对吧？那很简单。预订 Sunwing 的假期。有了这些“黑色星期五”优惠，你很快就能去海滩度假了。嗯。其实，Sunwing 的这些“黑色星期五”优惠从财务角度来看太划算了。请联系您的当地旅行顾问预订，或访问... Sunwing.ca 纳尔逊抬头望向天空。东方乌云密布。
In ancient times, he thought, people would have considered that a disturbing omen. But was it bad news for him or for the French? Upon this mission depended the fate of the war, perhaps even the survival of Britain. But he felt no fear, just a quiet, calm resolve. He nodded to his lieutenants. It was time to leave, to face his destiny. As darkness fell across the Mediterranean, they sailed through the Straits of Gibraltar east into the unknown. So it is the 8th of May 1798 and Dominic, as the storm clouds of war gather, brilliant metaphor there that we've never had on the rest of history before, Horatio Nelson is
他想，在古代，人们会认为这是个不祥之兆。但这对他还是对法国人来说是个坏消息呢？这场任务关乎战争的命运，甚至可能关乎英国的存亡。但他没有感到丝毫恐惧，只有一种平静而坚定的决心。他向副官们点了点头。是时候离开，去面对他的命运了。随着夜幕降临地中海，他们驶过直布罗陀海峡，向东驶入未知的世界。现在是1798年5月8日，多米尼克，随着战争的风云变幻——这是一个我们以前在《历史的余烬》中从未用过的绝妙比喻——霍雷肖·纳尔逊正
preparing to sail into the Mediterranean in search of Britain's greatest foe, Napoleon Bonaparte. And people wondering where they can find this masterly prose and this excellent analysis of naval warfare in the age of Napoleon. Why? It's a new book from a leading naval scholar, one Dominic Sandbrook, Nelson hero of the seas. And Dominicic I believe it's available from all good bookshops now, right? It is Tom and it's aimed at readers of all ages. So younger readers especially I think it's fair to say but if you're an older reader don't feel inhibited. Piling. Yeah, buy multiple copies for friends and family I would say.
准备驶入地中海，寻找英国最大的敌人拿破仑·波拿巴。人们一定在想，去哪儿能找到这种大师级的散文以及对拿破仑时代海战的出色分析呢？为什么？这是一本来自顶尖海军学者的全新力作，作者正是多米尼克·桑德布鲁克，书名是《纳尔逊：海洋英雄》。多米尼克，我想现在各大书店都能买到吧？是的，汤姆，这本书适合各个年龄段的读者阅读。所以我认为特别适合年轻读者，不过如果你是一位年长的读者，也别觉得有什么不好意思的。没错。是的，我会建议为亲朋好友多买几本。
Yeah Christmas is coming. And Tom do you know what? We're recording this on Trafalgar Day. I know. On the 21st of October. I've been aglow with patriotic fervour since I leapt out of bed. Have you? Oh, that's great news. It's the best day of the year. It is the best day of the year. It's Christmas for a historian, isn't it? Absolutely it is. Oh, not all historians. No, no. Certainly for us. If you're an academic historian, I think it's a day like any other. But for those of us who ply our trade in the public eye, it's a great moment isn't it? Trafalgar Day.
对，圣诞节快到了。汤姆，你知道吗？我们录制这期节目的今天正是特拉法加日。我知道。在10月21日。自从我从床上跳起来的那一刻起，我的爱国热情就一直高涨。是吗？哦，那太好了。这是一年中最棒的一天。这确实是一年中最棒的一天。对历史学家来说，这就是圣诞节，对吧？绝对是的。哦，并非所有历史学家都这么认为。不，不。对我们来说绝对是。如果你是一个学院派历史学家，我想这和其他日子没什么两样。但对于我们这些在公众视野中谋生的人来说，这是一个伟大的时刻，不是吗？特拉法加日。
It truly is. But we're not talking about the Battle of Trafalgar, we are talking about the campaign that culminates in another of Nelson's remarkable victories, the Battle of the Nile. But Dominic, we've got a long way before we get there, haven't we? We have because this is the amazing story of the hunt for Bonaparte today's episode. And actually last time, Tom, we ended with Nelson really in the doldrums, so he had been incredibly brave at the Battle of Capus and Vincent. Then he had led this very reckless and foolhardy attack on Tenerife to try and
确实如此。但我们今天不是在谈论特拉法加海战，我们要谈的是最终促成纳尔逊又一次卓越胜利——尼罗河战役——的军事行动。不过，多米尼克，在我们到达那里之前，还有很长一段路要走，不是吗？是的，因为这是今天这期节目中搜寻波拿巴的惊人故事。实际上，上一次，汤姆，我们在节目结束时，纳尔逊正处于极度低谷，他在圣文森特角海战中表现得极其勇敢。然后他又领导了那次非常鲁莽和愚蠢的特内里费岛袭击，试图和他的好友托马斯·特鲁布里奇一起
snatch the Spanish treasure with his mate Thomas Truebridge. And listeners will recall that it was a harebrained scheme. They turned up on the beach, dawn breaking, bells ringing, cannons firing at them. Nelson is shot in the elbow, rescued by his oafish stepson, Josiah. Josiah, who ties a tourniquet, uses his neckerchief. Nelson carried back to the ship, refuses to accept a chair to bring him up to the ship, so clambers
抢夺西班牙的财宝。听众们可能还记得，那是一个极其荒唐的计划。他们出现在海滩上，黎明破晓，钟声敲响，大农炮向他们开火。纳尔逊的手肘中枪，被他那笨手笨脚的继子约西亚救了出来。约西亚用颈巾给他做了个止血带。纳尔逊被抬回船上，拒绝坐椅子被抬上去，于是用他仅存的一只胳膊
up with his one arm. And Theo, who's French, didn't believe that. I mean, the thing is, if you start doubting any element of Nelson's life, then the whole story falls apart. But also the thing with Nelson's life that makes it such an extraordinary, irresistible subject is that these sort of Hollywood touches that we can scoff at, and I think by and large they genuinely did happen, didn't they? Nelson consistently behaved in an almost preposterously... Heroic manner. Yeah, melodramatic and heroic manner.
艰难地爬了上去。西奥是个法国人，他才不信这事呢。我的意思是，问题在于，如果你开始怀疑纳尔逊生平的任何一个细节，那么整个故事就会分崩离析。但同样地，纳尔逊生平中使他成为一个如此非凡、不可抗拒的主题的原因在于，那些我们可以嘲笑的好莱坞式的点缀，而且我认为大体上它们确实发生了，不是吗？纳尔逊一直表现得近乎荒谬地…… 英雄主义。对，既有戏剧性又充满英雄主义。
But he's quite depressed, isn't he? Obviously, he's lost his arm and he's suffered a defeat. Yes. And he tells him Vincent, who is his great patron now, that basically, you know, it's all up for him, that he will be a burden to my friends and useless to my country. He was going to go off to a cottage, wasn't he? No one will want a one armed admiral. Yeah, just kind of lick his wounds and be miserable. But actually when he arrives in Portsmouth, so he lands there on the afternoon of the 2nd of September 1797, for the first time he is greeted as a public hero.
但他挺沮丧的，对吧？显然，他失去了手臂，还遭遇了一场败绩。是的。他告诉圣文森特，也就是他现在的强大赞助商，基本上，你知道的，他的人生全完了，他将成为朋友们的累赘，对国家也毫无用处。他打算去乡间隐居，对吧？没有人会想要一个独臂上将。对，就是那种去舔舐伤口、自怨自艾的状态。但实际上，当他抵达朴次茅斯时——也就是1797年9月2日下午他在那里登陆——他第一次被当作国家英雄受到欢迎。
Yeah, because Nelson himself had made sure that the news of the battle of Cape St Vincent placed him at the centre. So he had written letters to friends and things. I mean, not unjustifiably. No, not unjustifiably, but one of Nelson's perhaps more irritating traits for his superiors, more amusing ones for us, is that he's an inveterate self promoter. He's very keen that everybody in England knows that he was in the thick of the action. Hashtag Nelson, hashtag St. Vincent. Exactly, exactly.
对，因为纳尔逊自己确保了圣文森特角海战的消息将他置于核心地位。所以他写信给朋友们之类的人。我的意思是，这并非毫无道理。不，并非毫无道理，但纳尔逊身上一个对他上司来说或许更令人恼火、对我们来说则更引人入胜的特点，就是他是一个根深蒂固的自我宣传者。他非常渴望英国的每个人都知道他身处战斗的最核心。话题标签：纳尔逊，话题标签：圣文森特。没错，没错。
Hashtag victory. And when he arrives, as you say, at Portsmouth, he's a very wizened and kind of miserable looking figure because he's been very ill, he's lost his arm, he's suffered a terrible defeat at Tenerife. But there's this little crowd there and they kind of shout three cheers for, you know. Yeah, hazzars. Hazzars, all this.
话题标签：胜利。当他如你所说抵达朴次茅斯时，他看起来非常消瘦、愁容满面，因为他病得很重，失去了手臂，在特内里费岛遭遇了惨痛的失败。但那里有一小群人，他们高呼三声万岁，为了…… 嗯，欢呼。欢呼，诸如此类。
And he is, I think, surprised by this because he's obviously been so low. Wasn't expecting it. And it gives him a little boost. And actually, this is the first time, as you say, that he becomes a national figure. So when he arrives in Bath to be reunited with his father Edmund and his wife Fanny, the newspapers in Bath, the local papers all report the stories. So there are lots of extracts in for example, John Sugden's biography saying, you know, the Bath bugle or whatever will say, Oh, wonderful news. The hero of the Battle
我想他对此感到惊讶，因为他之前的心情显然低落到了极点。完全没有预料到。这给了他一点鼓舞。实际上，正如你所说，这是他第一次成为全国知名的人物。因此，当他抵达巴斯与他的父亲埃德蒙和妻子范妮团聚时，巴斯当地的报纸都报道了这些故事。因此，比如在约翰·萨格登（John Sugden）的传记中就有大量摘录，上面写着《巴斯号角报》或其他什么报纸会说：“哦，太棒了！圣文森特角海战的英雄已经来到了镇上，他将在温泉区散步，去剧院看戏等等，我们所有人都能见到他，这难道不是很棒吗？”因为实际上这一切都关乎圣文森特，不是吗？他们并没有怎么提及特内里费岛。没有。即使是那些说那次行动有点笨拙的报纸，我的意思是，它们仍然会说，他非常勇敢。所以他并没有因为特内里费岛的失利而受到过多的批评。他依然是当之无愧的英雄。你想读一首小诗吗？你想读读《巴斯先驱报》上的那首诗吗？
of Cape St. Vincent has arrived in the town and he's going to be strolling around the spas and go into the theater and stuff and we can all see him and isn't that wonderful? Because actually it's all about St Vincent isn't it? They don't really mention Tenerife. No. Even the newspapers that do say that was a bit cack-handed. I mean they still say, well he was very brave. So he's not overly criticized for Tenerife. He is still the hero of the hour. Absolutely. Do you want to read a little bit of poetry? Would you like to read the poem from the Bath Herald?
我很乐意，因为我实际上对以纳尔逊为主题的诗歌非常感兴趣。我们之前已经提到了拜伦，他称纳尔逊为“不列颠的战神”；柯勒律治和骚赛也非常热衷于此。威廉·布莱克——我们可能也会讲到他——曾画过一幅非凡的纳尔逊画像。这首诗或许在水平上无法完全与拜伦、柯勒律治和布莱克相提并论，但它是献给那位无畏的海军上将霍雷肖·纳尔逊爵士的，庆祝他从危险与荣耀的场景中归来，回到这座城市中他家人的怀抱。那句话里有很多大写字母。哦，纳尔逊，我们赞颂的对象，愿清醒的价值将装饰你未来的日子，在天伦之乐的慰藉中，
I would love to because I'm actually very interested in the topic of Nelson as a theme for poetry. So we've already mentioned Byron, who called him Britannia's God of War, Coleridge and Southey, they were very keen. William Blake, who we'll probably come to, did an extraordinary painting of Nelson. But this is maybe not entirely up there with Byron and Coleridge and Blake, but it was dedicated to that intrepid Admiral Sir Horatio Nelson on his arrival from scenes of danger and glory to the arms of his family in the city. And there are a lot of capital letters in that sentence. Oh Nelson, subject of our praise, while conscious worth shall guild thy future days, soothed
一位慈祥的父亲和一位忠贞的妻子。天哪，汤姆，这真是讽刺。是的，这很快就会带有一种痛苦的讽刺意味。当然，范妮一直是个非常忠贞的妻子，对吧？是的，问题在于纳尔逊会不会是一个忠贞的丈夫。没错，没错。因此，他于那年秋天晚些时候回到家中，前往伦敦，并被授予伦敦城的荣誉市民称号（Freedom of the City）以及由市长颁发的礼仪之剑。他前往圣詹姆斯宫，
with the blessings of domestic life, a reverent father and a faithful wife. Oh dear, Tom, the irony. Yeah, that will soon have a bitterly ironic meaning. Of course, Fanny is always a very faithful wife, isn't she? Yeah, it's a question of whether Nelson will be a faithful husband. Exactly, exactly. So he's come home later that autumn, he goes off to London and he's given the freedom of the city and a ceremonial sword by the Lord Mayor. He goes to St James's Palace with
同行的有圣文森特伯爵（前身为约翰·杰维斯爵士）。在那里，正处于疯癫与对着树木说话之间的间歇期的国王乔治三世，授予了他巴斯骑士勋章的银星和深红色绶带。多米尼克，乔治三世以前对纳尔逊一直挺有成见的，对吧？因为纳尔逊曾被委任负责照顾他的儿子威廉——也就是后来的克拉伦斯公爵——而国王觉得他没照顾好。他确实没照顾好。但现在乔治三世已经原谅了纳尔逊。
the Earl of St Vincent, formerly Sir John Jervis, and there George III, who's in one of the intervals between being mad and talking to trees, gives him the silver star and crimson ribbon of a knight of the Order of the Bath. Dominic, George III had been quite down on Nelson, hadn't he? Because Nelson had been given responsibility for looking after his son, William, who's become the Duke of Clarence and felt that he'd done it poorly. He had done it poorly. But now George III has forgiven Nelson.
正是如此。是的，因为人们会记得纳尔逊当时在照顾——他当时被称为威廉·亨利，对吧？也就是未来的威廉四世。当他成为国王、成为威廉四世时，每个人都觉得他很随和。直率。对，直率这个词。在描述他时，法律规定你必须使用这个词。但实际上，作为一个年轻人，他绝对是一个糟糕透顶的人。
That's right. Yes, because people will remember that Nelson was looking after, he was called William Henry at the time, wasn't he? Your future William the fourth. And when he's the king, when he's William the fourth, everybody thinks of him as jolly. Bluff. Yeah. Bluff is the word. You're legally required to use that word when describing him. But actually as a young man, he was just an absolutely dreadful person.
他就是那种——这就是我们的制作人跟我们讲过的那些因为穿斜纹棉裤和蓝色衬衫而被学生会禁止入内的人。这难道不是那些喝醉酒并骚扰所有人的冰球队公立学校男生吗？这就是威廉·亨利，对吧？这绝对就是威廉·亨利。而且跟纳尔逊一点也不像。是的。无论如何，纳尔逊被封为巴斯骑士，他可以设计自己的徽章，而且他真的是全力以赴，对吧？所以他的徽章上有一名英国水手在踩踏一面西班牙国旗，还有一只狮子用牙齿把
He was the kind of person, that's the thing that our producers were telling us about people being banned from student unions when they wear chinos and blue shirts. Isn't that public school boys who are in hockey teams who get drunk and harass everybody. This is William Henry, isn't it? This is absolutely William Henry. And very much not Nelson. Yeah. Anyway, Nelson's been made a knight of the bath and he gets to choose his own coat of arms and he absolutely goes for it, doesn't he? So his coat of arms has got a British sailor stamping on a Spanish flag and a lion ripping
一面西班牙国旗撕成碎片。名副其实。是的。这肯定不会受到那位衣着考究的西班牙国王的欢迎。对，他们可以把它挂在直布罗陀上空。欢迎来到直布罗陀。对，完全可以，他们就该这么做。
a Spanish flag apart with his teeth. Does what it says on the tin. Yeah. Would not be popular with the well-dressed King of Spain. No, they could fly it over. Welcome to Gibraltar. Yeah, exactly. That's what they should do.
所以，我想我们不应该低估纳尔逊的残疾。是的，一点也不能。因为，我的意思是，这是一件非常非常严重的事情，对吧？他一只眼睛失明了。他的手臂肘部以上截肢了。他早上无法好好给自己穿衣服。甚至连扣上马裤、系好外套、穿上袜子以及诸如此类的事情都做不到。
So we shouldn't underplay Nelson's disability, I suppose. No, not at all. Because, I mean, it's a really, really serious business, isn't it? He can't see out of one eye. He's lost this arm above the elbow. He can't dress himself properly in the morning. Like even to do up his britches, to fasten his coat, to put his stockings on and all this kind of thing.
这就像是一项真正的体力活。所以他很幸运能有一个忠贞的妻子来帮他，对吧？嗯，范妮对他的照顾真是无微不至。她从不抱怨，而且非常有耐心。所以他确实有一些专门为他定制的物品。他有特制的衬衫，就像你一样，汤姆。对，就像我一样。手工制作的衬衫。他有一把特殊的叉子。我不知道你有没有这样的叉子。那是他们的朋友制作的一种叉子。它有点像是多用途叉勺（spork）的祖先。一半是叉子，一半是刀。所以你可以带着它去露营。
It's like a real effort. So it's lucky he's got a faithful wife, isn't it, to help him. Well Fanny is amazing for him. She's so uncomplaining and patient and stuff. So he does have some things that are especially done for him. He has specially made shirts, like you Tom. Yeah, like me. Handmade shirts. He has a special fork. I don't know if you have a fork like this. It's a fork their friend makes. It's like an ancestor of the spork. Kind of half fork, half knife. So you could take it camping.
这基本上是一把绝佳的露营叉。我的意思是，他在公共场合切食物时会觉得非常丢脸，对吧？因为他要在盘子里追着一块块肉切来切去。是的。对于一个把自己想象成尤利乌斯·恺撒或亚历山大大帝似的人物来说，这可真不是什么好形象，对吧？不，确实不太符合那个气场。
It's a brilliant camping fork basically. I mean he finds the effort of cutting up food in public very humiliating doesn't he? Because he's kind of chasing bits of meat around his plate and things. Yeah. For somebody who fancies himself as a bit of a kind of you know Julius Caesar or Alexander the Great. It's not the image is it? No, not quite the look.
不，这不符合那个气场。不过我认为，最重要的是，这简直是难以想象的形象，对吧？不，确实不太符合那个气场。不，这不符合那个气场。不过我认为，最重要的是，这简直是难以想象的痛，对吧？我不太理解其中的医疗情况，但有一根丝线没有脱落，这给他带来了巨大的痛苦，这意味着伤口无法愈合。是这样吗？我想我没记错吧。对，就是这样。
No, it's not the look. But I think I mean more than anything it's just unbelievably image, is it? No, not quite the look. No, it's not the look. But I think, I mean, more than anything, it's just unbelievably painful, isn't it? I don't entirely understand the medicine of it, but there's a strand of silk that hasn't dropped off and this is causing him immense pain and it means that the wound can't heal. Is that right? I think I've got that right. Yeah, that's exactly it.
所以他手臂末端的伤口依然敞开着，因为这根丝线没有脱落。他去伦敦看了一位外科医生，外科医生说：“听着，它最终会掉下来的。我们无能为力，但在这种情况下，你真的不能去海上，因为伤口可能会感染。”而且，他在狂饮大量的鸦片酊（laudanum），对吧？是的，他确实在喝。所以他正处于嗑了鸦片的状态。没错。
So the wound is still open at the end of his arm because this silk thread has not fallen away and he goes to see a surgeon in London and the surgeon says, look, it will eventually. There's nothing we can do, but you can't go to sea really while this is the case because this could get infected. Well, also he's necking vast quantities of Lordenum, isn't he? Yeah, he is. So he's off his face on opium. He is.
不过他的情绪与这个国家的状态完美契合。英国现在已经与革命法国战斗了五年之久，时间远远超出了任何人的想象。事实证明，革命法国是一个比预期更具韧性、甚至不仅仅是有韧性、而是极其强大的对手。人们会记得，英国舰队曾被迫撤出地中海。英国的盟友像苍蝇一样纷纷退出战争。这场战争代价高昂。法国人甚至一度在威尔士菲什加德（Fishguard）登陆了一小股突袭部队。这是一个很棒的故事，对吧？当地城镇的妇女们戴着威尔士帽子排成队列，法国人把她们误当作了掷弹兵之类的人。是的。是的，然后就投降了。这是威尔士妇女的一场伟大胜利。
So his mood though is perfectly matched to that of the country. Britain has been fighting now for five years against revolutionary France, far longer than anybody imagined. France has proved a much more resilient and indeed more than resilient, a formidable opponent, revolutionary France. The British fleet, people will remember, has been forced out of the Mediterranean. Britain's allies are dropping out of the war like flies. It's proved very expensive. The French have actually landed at one point a little raiding party at Fishguard in Wales. There's a great story, isn't it? The local town's women lined up in their Welsh hats and the French mistook them for grenadiers or whatever. Yeah. Yeah. And surrendered on that. A great victory for the women of Wales.
但那次小型入侵的消息引发了一场金融恐慌。因此，英格兰银行遭到了巨额挤兑。许多乡村银行倒闭了。如果你读过珍妮·乌格洛（Jenny Uglo）关于英国与拿破仑战争的出色著作，你就会发现里面充斥着各种类似乡村牧师之类的人在1797年这个时间点的书信。所以我们将会和她做一期加更节目。是的。
But news of that little invasion sparked a financial panic. So there was a huge run on the Bank of England. A lot of country banks collapsed. And if you read Jenny Uglo's brilliant book about Britain and the Napoleonic Wars, she has all this stuff with kind of letters from country Parsons and things at this point, 1797. So we will be doing a bonus with her. Yeah.
所以如果你是“历史的余烬俱乐部”的成员，我们将与她探讨那本书。那是一本关于1790年代英国的精彩著作。生活在1793年至1815年拿破仑战争期间的英国。绝对是一本奇书。无论如何，接着在1797年春天——也就是纳尔逊归来几个月前——爆发了一波海军哗变浪潮。斯皮特黑德（Spithead）发生了一场哗变，随后诺尔（The Nore）也发生了哗变，哗变者甚至对泰晤士河实施了封锁。我的意思是，对于英国皇家海军来说，这是绝对的最低谷，是一个令人震惊的时刻——英国的剑与盾竟然会以这种方式遭到破坏。但令人惊奇的是，纳尔逊对斯皮特黑德的哗变者非常同情，
So if you remember the Restless History Club, we will be talking to her about that book. And that's a brilliant book about Britain in the 1790s. Living in Britain through Napoleon's War 1793 to 1815. Absolutely wonderful book. Anyway, then there are a wave of mutinies in the spring of 1797, a few months before Nelson's return. There's been a mutiny at Spithead, then there's been a mutiny at the Knorr and a blockade of the Thames actually by the mutineers. I mean, this for the Royal Navy is an absolute nadir, is a shocking moment that the sword and shield of Britain can be disrupted in this way. But what's amazing about this is that Nelson is very sympathetic to the Spithead mutineers
他觉得他们受到了不公的对待。这非常符合他的“贵族义务”（noblesse oblige）理念，即高阶军官对底层士兵负有照顾的责任。因此，关于斯皮特黑德哗变，他说了这样一番话——我读到时感到非常震惊：“这是我听说过的最具有男子气概的事情，为英国水手赢得了无上的荣誉。”这是他对克拉伦斯公爵说的，而公爵本想把他们统统绞死。纳尔逊却说：“不，不，我们对他们负有责任。”不过，他确实将诺尔哗变的主谋视为雅各宾党人，认为他们在误导诚实的英国水手。而且他完全赞成把他们统统挂在帆桁（yardarm）上绞死，我想实际上
who he feel have been badly done by. This is very much his kind of noblesse oblige that those in the higher ranks owe a duty of care to those low down. And so he said of the spithead mutiny, I was amazed to read this, the most manly thing I ever heard of and does the British sailor infinite honor. And that's what he says to the Duke of Clarence who's hang them all. And he says, no, no, we have a duty to them. He does view the ringleaders of the Norm mutiny though as Jacobins who are kind of misleading the honest British tar. And he'd be all in favour of hanging them from the yardarm, which I think actually is
他们也确实被绞死了，不是吗？是的，他们被绞死了。主谋都被绞死了。我想是因为当时有几件不同的事情同时发生。一方面是对低薪的可以理解的焦虑和怨恨。他们已经在海上待了很久，战争被无限期拖延，食物糟糕，等等诸如此类的事情。另一方面，在某些人当中存在着激进的情绪，而这两种情绪混杂在了一起。
what happens to them. I think they do all get hanged, don't they? Yes, they are hanged. The ringleaders are hanged. I think because there's a couple of different things happening at once. One is understandable anxiety and resentment at the kind of low pay. The fact they've been at sea for ages, the war is dragged on, bad food, all of that stuff. And then among some people, there's a radical sentiment and those two things have become mixed up.
就是在诺尔发生的情况。是的。无论如何，对于英国民众来说，在经历了这一切之后又听到哗变的消息，实在是令人震惊。接着在1797年10月，英国最后一个主要盟友奥地利与法国单独签署了和平条约。你瞧，英国再次孤立无援，这已经不是第一次了。当时发生了一个惊人的场景，首相威廉·皮特在下议院发表了演讲。
That's at the North. Yeah. Anyway, for people in Britain, the news of the mutinies on top of everything else is really shocking. And then in October 1797, Britain's last major ally, Austria, signs a separate peace with France. And wouldn't you know it, not for the last time, Britain stands alone. And there's an amazing scene actually, William Pitt, the prime minister, gets up in the Commons.
当然，皮特在今天已经被大多数人遗忘了，但这绝对是一个具有丘吉尔风格的时刻。他说：“宁可面对伴随着荣誉的危险。”——他可不是这么讲话的。他说的是“伴随着荣誉的危险”。因为他当时大约10岁。你得用他的声音腔调来模仿。否则就没效果。
And of course, Pitt is largely forgotten today, but it's a very Churchillian moment. He says, better to face danger accompanied with honor. That's not how he speaks. He says danger accompanied with honor. Cause he's about 10. You've got to do it in search of his voice. Otherwise it doesn't work.
“……也绝不接受不可磨灭的羞辱与耻辱。”不可磨灭的羞辱与耻辱。听众们可以自行判断谁模仿得更准确。好吧，我的意思是，威廉·皮特是一个非常令人印象深刻的人。所以我不认为他听起来会像汤姆的版本。老实说，汤姆的版本是来自《黑爵士》（Blackadder）。无论如何，皮特说，我们需要继续战斗。我们不能放弃构成英格兰骄傲、
Then to accept indelible shame and disgrace. Indelible shame and disgrace. And listeners can decide who's more accurate there. Well, I mean, he's a very impressive man, William Pitt. So I don't think he sounded like Tom's version. Tom's version is from Blackadder, let's be honest. Anyway, Pitt says, we need to fight on. We can't surrender everything that constitutes the pride, the
安全与幸福的一切。他说，所有生而自由的英国人都必须携手同心，庄严承诺为我们国家的法律、自由与宗教而战。这番话极具煽动力，但实际上，这也是他大幅增税的借口。对，所以这有点像蕾切尔·里夫斯（Rachel Reeves）的财政黑洞，对吧？完全是的。他将税收提高了三倍，并宣布开征第一笔所得税。
safety and happiness of England. And he says all freeborn Britons must join hand and heart in a solemn pledge to fight for this laws, liberties and religion of our country. This is very stirring stuff, but actually this is the pretext for him to massively increase taxes. Yeah, so it's kind of Rachel Reeves fiscal black hole, isn't it? Exactly. He trebles taxes and announces the first income tax.
因此，如果你是高收入者，你收入超过200英镑的部分必须缴纳十分之一的税。而且众所周知，他还将窗户税提高了三倍。他确实这么做了。所以你有时看到的那些被砖砌堵住的窗户，就是从这个时候开始的。为了逃税。 exatamente。因此，士气相当低落，我想这样说并不过分。
So if you're a high earner, you will pay a tenth of your income over £200. And also notoriously, he triples the window tax. He does indeed. So all the bricked up windows that you sometimes see are from this moment. Tax evasion. Exactly. So morale is pretty low, I think it's fair to say.
就在这时，纳尔逊收到了一封信。他收到了一份邀请函，邀请他参加一场旨在提振士气的游行。国王想要庆祝他们在海上取得的三大战役的胜利。其中之一就是圣文森特角海战，纳尔逊曾参与其中对抗西班牙人。他们在坎珀当（Camperdown）对阵荷兰人时也取得了巨大的胜利。这太惊人了，不是吗？因为那是哗变发生仅几周后进行的战斗。是的。我想那是邓肯上将（Admiral Duncan），就像Soho区的那个同性恋酒吧一样。我想是的，没错。那我来告诉你 N.A.M.罗杰（N.A.M. Roger）对那场战役是怎么说的。我很想
And Nelson, at this point, gets a letter. He gets an invitation to go to a parade to bolster morale. The king wants to celebrate the three great victories they've had at sea. So that's Capes and Vincent and Nelson was involved against the Spanish. They won a tremendous victory at Camperdown against the Dutch. And that's amazing, isn't it? Because that's fought only a few weeks after the mutinies. Yes. I think it's Admiral Duncan, as in the gay pub in Soho. I think that's right, yes. So I'll tell you what N.A.M. Roger said of that. I'd love to
听听。关于坎珀当战役：“它首次赋予了英国皇家海军某种无敌的光环，这种光环此前一直笼罩在法国陆军的头上。”我的意思是，他对此当然深有体会。这大概就是他们为什么要举行这场游行的原因。正是如此。因为本质上，这是他们唯一的正面好消息。好吧，他们确实赢得了三场泰坦尼克号级别的海战。第三场被称为一场拥有一个极其辉煌名字的战役——“光荣的六月一日”
hear it. Of Camperdown. It bestowed for the first time on the Royal Navy something of the aura of invincibility which now hung about the French armies on land. I mean he'd know about that. And this presumably is why they're having this parade. That's right. Because essentially it's the only good new story they have. Well they have won three Titanic naval battles. The third one was called a battle with a brilliant name of the glorious 1st of June
因为这场战役是在大西洋的荒凉深处进行的，那是前一年针对法国人的战斗，所以他们分别战胜了西班牙人、荷兰人和法国人。在此之前，胜利通常不会伴随游行庆祝，因为人们认为这有点民粹主义、流于粗俗，是那种…… 并且带有革命法国的雅各宾党行为，但政府觉得他们确实非常需要这场游行。于是他们在12月19日举行了游行。天气冰冷刺骨，但成千上万的民众涌上街头。纳尔逊身穿他的巴斯骑士勋章制服，负责将西班牙国旗交还给圣保罗大教堂的教长，这某种程度上也是对他新获得的名气的致敬。但正如约翰·萨格登在他的传记中所说，这一刻充满了阴影与讽刺，因为就在这个地方，仅仅八年之后，他的遗体将在英国历史上最著名的国葬中长眠于此。
because it's fought in the middle of nowhere in the Atlantic and that was against the French a year earlier so they've had three victories against the Spanish the Dutch and the French and Previously victories had not been greeted by parades because they were seen as kind of populist vulgar kind of thing people do actually and Revolutionary France Jacob in behavior, but the government feels they really need this parade. So they have it on the 19th of December. It's freezing cold, but tens of thousands of people turn out. Nelson wears his Order of the Bath and he's in charge of handing the Spanish flags to the Dean of St Paul's Cathedral, which is a kind of tribute to his new found celebrity. But also as John Sugden says in his biography, this is a moment kind of shadowed with irony because it's on this very spot in just eight years time that his own body will rest in the most famous state funeral in British history.
这就是为什么他的故事具有如此史诗般的品质。我的意思是，它充满了各种各样的讽刺、预示和回响。太惊人了。确实。因此，这场盛大游行之后的几周相当惨淡。每个人都对税收感到非常焦虑，也对英国如今在欧洲陷入孤立的现状忧心忡忡。人们有一种强烈的感受，即英国几乎是带着一丝不情愿在为这场全面斗争做准备。这显然已经是一种与七年战争截然不同的战争了，我认为。
And this is why his story has such a quality of epic. I mean, it's full of these kind of ironies and foreshadowings and echoes. It's amazing. Exactly. So the weeks after this great parade are quite bleak. Everybody is very anxious about the taxes and about the fact that Britain is now isolated in Europe. And there's a real sense, I think, about Britain gearing up almost reluctantly for this kind of total struggle. It is clearly now a different kind of war from even the Seven
这是一场在财政上要求更高、在情感上也要求更高的战争，是一场真正意义上的全国性运动。也正是在这个时候，威廉·皮特的某些间谍开始带来一些风声，称海峡对岸的法国人正在集结军队、备战船只。他们最终发现，作为这支新军队的最高指挥官，统治法国的督政府（The Directory）已经任命了那位在意大利所向披靡的人物。这当然就是科西嘉人拿破仑·波拿巴。而没有人知道的是
Years War, I think. It is a much more financially demanding and kind of emotionally demanding war, a genuinely national campaign. And it's about this point that some of William Pitt's spies start to bring whispers that on the other side of the channel, the French are massing troops and preparing ships. And they eventually discover that as the supreme commander of this new army, the directory who are running France have appointed the man who had carried all before him in Italy. And this of course is the Corsican Napoleon Bonaparte. And what nobody knows
——他们是在策划对海峡对岸船坞的进攻吗？查塔姆（Chatham），汤姆？查塔姆和朴次茅斯。因为我们之前讨论过这个，不是吗？对法国来说，能将英国踢出战争的唯一真正方法就是摧毁这些造船厂。是的，如果你摧毁了造船厂并夺取了海峡的控制权，你就可以登陆军队。你甚至不一定非得登陆。如果你能控制海峡，就能将英国困死、切断英国的物资供应。他们将被迫妥协。是的，那样英国就别无选择，只能妥协了。所以没有人真正知道他们的计划是什么，但到了早春，越来越多的传言
is, are they planning an attack on the dockyards across the channel? Chatham, Tom? Chatham and Portsmouth. Because we discussed this before, didn't we, that that would be the only way really that France could knock Britain out of the war would be to destroy the dockyards. Yeah, if you destroy the dockyards and win control of the channel, you could then land troops. You don't necessarily need to. If you can control the channel, starve Britain out, starve Britain of supplies. They'd be reduced to terms. Yeah, then Britain would have no choice but to come to terms. So no one really knows what their plan is, but by the early spring there are more rumours
和间谍报告等消息传到伦敦，指向法国南部的土伦（Toulon），而土伦当然已经被拿破仑重新攻占了。你还记得那个经过法医般考究的场景吗？拿破仑眺望着土伦冒烟的港口。我记得当时他嘴角挂着一丝残酷的微笑，对吧，汤姆？但大概是因为他患有疥疮，那是他在捡起手套时传染上的，对吧？没错，记性真好。正是在那场围城战中。
reaching London and spy reports and things than the south of France in Toulon, which of course had been retaken by Napoleon. You remember that forensically researched scene of Napoleon looking out across the smoking harbour of Toulon. A cruel smile, I think was playing on his lips, wasn't it Tom? But presumably because he had scabies, which he'd got from picking up the glove, wasn't it? That's right, well remembered. In the course of that siege.
对，他就像个邦德电影里的反派。他不仅残酷暴虐，而且身体因疥疮而畸形。没错。因此，从土伦传来的消息称，这个名叫弗朗索瓦·保罗·布吕埃（François-Paul Brueys）的海军上将正在集结一支拥有十多艘军舰和数百艘运输船的舰队。伦敦的人们一周又一周地争论的问题是：这支武装力量——他们这么称呼它——究竟要开往何方？因此有传言说他们要去希腊，
Yeah, he's like a Bond villain. He's not just cruel and despotic, but he's physically malformed with scabies. Right. So from Toulon, there are reports of this guy, Admiral Francois Paul Brues is assembling a fleet with more than a dozen warships and hundreds of transports. And the question which people in London are debating for week after week is where is the armament as they call it? Where is it heading? So there are rumors that they're going to Greece,
波拿巴把目光投向了那不勒斯或西西里、君士坦丁堡，甚至可能是埃及，但没有人能确定。最终，海军部决定：“好吧，我们要派遣一支新的分舰队返回地中海，去查明这支在土伦集结的庞大力量究竟在搞什么鬼。”同时也为了展示国旗，试图说服奥地利人想方设法重新加入战争。但这无疑是一场豪赌，对吧？
that Bonaparte has his eye set on Naples or Sicily, Constantinople, maybe even Egypt, but nobody knows for certain. And eventually the Admiralty decides, right, we will send a new squadron back to the Mediterranean to find out what on earth is going on with this enormous force being assembled in too long. But also because we want to fly the flag to try and persuade the Austrian somehow to get back into the war. But it's a gamble, isn't it?
当然。因为进入地中海的舰船必须从圣文森特的舰队中抽调，而圣文森特正忙于封锁加的斯（Cadiz）并巡逻伊比利亚半岛的大西洋海岸线。正是如此。因此，他的舰队反过来又必须得到来自海峡舰队的增援。所以从本质上讲，只要英国舰队留守地中海，海峡舰队就将没有任何战略预备队。所以这确实是一场赌博。是的，但你不能只是放任这个庞大的舰队四处横行而置之不理。那是因为你是纳尔逊，而我是霍夫曼（Hoffman）。这关乎那种神经质的抽搐。你当时什么都不会做，告诉我你会选择固守待命。我会的。
Of course. Because the ships that will go into the Mediterranean have to come from St Vincent's fleet, which are busy blocking cadiz and patrolling the Atlantic seaboard of Iberia. That's right. So his fleet in turn has to be reinforced by ships from the Channel. So essentially for as long as the British fleet is in the Mediterranean, the Channel fleet will have no strategic reserve. So it is a gamble. Yeah, but you can't just allow this enormous fleet to rampage around unchecked. That's because you are Nelson and I am Hoffman. It's about the nervous twitchy. You would have done nothing, tell me you'd hunkered down. I would.
噢不，那你就会输掉拿破仑战争了。多么可怕的供认。我会的。我绝对会。但像你这样充满冲劲的人，如果你当时在那里，你就会获得指挥权，但这个任务最终却落在了纳尔逊头上。没错。是的，遗憾的是落在了纳尔逊头上。
Oh no, you'd have lost the Napoleonic Wars. What a terrible confession. I would. I absolutely would. But you with your dash, had you been there, you'd have been given the command, but instead it goes to Nelson. That's right. Yeah, sadly it goes to Nelson.
他被委任指挥“先锋号”（Vanguard）——一艘名字极佳的74门炮舰。上级告诉他：“我们希望你进入地中海，找到这支庞大的敌方舰队，并基本上汇报到底发生了什么。”他得到了这个指挥权，对吧？部分原因显然是因为他是当红人物。人们觉得他充满了冲劲和首创精神。但同时，我也认为是因为大家觉得他在地中海地缘政治方面也很有一套。因为显然英国在地中海没有港口，没有基地。所以他需要找到一些这样的地方，这需要谈判和外交手段。
He is given the Vanguard, excellent name for a ship, the 74 gun Vanguard, and he is told, we want you to go into the Mediterranean and find this colossal enemy fleet and basically report on what's going on. And he's given that command, isn't he? Partly, obviously, because he's the man of the hour. There's a sense that he's full of dash and initiative. But also, I think, because there's a feeling that he's good at geopolitics as well. Because presumably that British have no ports, no bases in the Mediterranean. And so he'll need to find some of those and that will require negotiation and diplomacy.
他确实需要。还有补给、水以及他们需要的各种物资。你需要一个真正精通这些事务的人，而他恰恰就是这样的人。我想，在处理文书工作方面他也很拿手。于是他向范妮告别。实际上，在这个时候，所有人都说霍雷肖和范妮非常亲密。他们看起来从未如此亲密。他们在伊普斯维奇附近的朗伍德（Round Wood）一起买了一座新房子。
He will indeed. And supplies and water and all of this kind of stuff that they will need. You need somebody who's really on top of this, which he absolutely is. On top of the paperwork side of things, I suppose. So he says farewell to Fanny. And actually at this point, everybody says Horatio and Fanny are very close. They have never seemed closer. They bought a new house together, round wood near Iberswitch.
种种迹象表明，他们正期待着把它装修成属于他们自己的家。有一个动人的故事：一天晚上，他和海军部第一大臣斯彭瑟勋爵（Lord Spencer）以及斯彭瑟夫人（这位大人的妻子）共进晚餐。斯彭瑟夫人后来回忆说，谈话转到了纳尔逊即将远行、留下范妮一人的话题上。他突然非常情绪激动地说道：“范妮是如此可爱，如此善良，又如此多才多艺，以至于我认为自己是英格兰最幸运的人。”
And the indications are they're looking forward to making it their own. And there's a lovely story that one evening he has dinner with the first Lord of the Admiralty, Lord Spencer and Lady Spencer, this guy's wife. And Lady Spencer remembered afterwards that the talk turned to how Nelson was going away and he'd be leaving Fanny behind. And he suddenly speaks very emotionally and he says, Fanny is so lovely and she's so kind and she's so accomplished that I regard myself as the luckiest man in England.
他说：“她对我天使般的温柔超越了想象。她为我包扎伤口，帮我切肉，帮我穿衣服，她做了所有这些事情。我真的认为，”他说，“她救了我的命，因为我当时太沮丧了，而她把我从阴影中拉了出来。”他对斯彭瑟夫人说：“如果我不在的时候发生什么意外，我希望你们能一直照顾范妮。”嗯，他不在的时候确实发生了意外。
Her angelic tenderness to me, he says, has been beyond imagination. She's dressed my wounds, she's cut up my meat, she's helped me get dressed, she's done all these things. And I really think, he says, that she's saved my life because I was so depressed and she's helped me out of it. And he says to Lady Spencer, if anything happens to me while I'm away, I hope you'll always look after Fanny. Well, something does happen to him while he's away.
是的。但并不是被炮弹击中。绝对不是什么好事。我想这样说并不过分，汤姆，绝对不是好事。你知道我对这件事的看法的。好吧，我们会讨论这一点的。那么，他在4月初乘坐“先锋号”从朴次茅斯启航。在随后的
Yes. But it doesn't involve a cannonball. Nothing good. I think it's fair to say, Tom, nothing good. You know, my views of this, of this business. Well, we will discuss this. Right. So he set sail from Portsmouth on the Vanguard at the beginning of April. And for
几周里，他一路向南航行。月底时，他抵达了你刚才提到的加的斯。约翰·杰维斯爵士——现在是圣文森特伯爵——正在那里封锁西班牙舰队。在拿破仑战争中有大量的封锁行动，讲起来简直无聊透顶。是吗？我倒觉得挺有意思的。我觉得关于物资补给的部分非常有趣。虽然什么也没发生。但这些船只能连续数月停留在海上并得到源源不断的补给。我的意思是，我发现这太神奇了，但这只是因为我对英国皇家海军的后勤学有着浓厚的兴趣。当然。
weeks he sails south. At the end of the month, he reaches, you mentioned Cadiz. That's where Sir John Jervis, now the Earl of St. Vincent, is blockading the Spanish fleet. There's an awful lot of blockading in the Napoleonic Wars, which is unbelievably boring to talk about. Is it? I think it is. I think it's quite interesting because I think the supplying of it is so interesting. Nothing happens. But the fact these ships can stay out for month after month after month and be supplied. I mean, I find it amazing, but that's because I have an intense
这或许就是我们之间的分歧所在。当然。我喜欢近距离交战，汤姆。我渴望投入近距离的战斗。你其实更喜欢霍瑟姆上将（Admiral Hotham）那种类型，他会很享受封锁战。完全正确。哦，让我们离大炮远点吧。完全正确。所以，“历史的余烬俱乐部”的会员们，你们可以期待汤姆来做那些加更节目了——讲述关于加的斯封锁战的日记式账户，最终以没有任何战斗收场告终。无论如何，他与圣文森特会合了。圣文森特说：“听着，我们没有关于法国人的任何消息。没有任何他们的踪迹。我们真的不知道发生了什么。”他对纳尔逊说：“我给你两艘船——‘俄里翁号’（Orion）和‘亚历山大号’（Alexander），再给你三艘较小的护卫舰。”
interest in the logistics of the Royal Navy. Of course. And that may be a point of difference between us. Of course. I like close action, Tom. I'm itching to get into close action. You like, like Admiral Hotham actually, he would enjoy a blockade. Exactly. Oh, let's not go anywhere near a cannon. Right. Exactly. So members of the Restless History Club, you can look forward to Tom doing those bonus
多米尼克，有没有哪本新出版的书籍描述了当时的场景？你想读一下，还是我来读？我来读好不好？你来读。我要读。请用我认为这篇散文应得的尊严和敬意来朗读它。我会的。我会的。所以，我们现在正走向第一部分的尾声，我想不出比朗读多米尼克关于纳尔逊的新书中的片段更好的方式了。圣文森特迎上了他朋友的目光，神情凝重。纳尔逊必须记住，他说道，
episodes about a day by day account of a blockade of cadets that ends with no fighting whatsoever. Anyway, he meets up with St Vincent. St Vincent says, look, we've had no news of the French. We've had no sign of them. We don't really have any sense of what's going on. And he says to him, I will give you two ships, the Orion and the Alexander, and I'll give you three smaller frigates.
一旦他向东驶过直布罗陀，他就将驶出救援范围之外。大多数地中海港口现在都忠于法国。如果他需要补给或维修，唯一可靠的港口就是那不勒斯。多亏了波拿巴，那不勒斯的独立已经命悬一线。命悬一线！纳尔逊点了点头。他知道其中的风险，但他也清楚其中的利害。
And Dominic is there a recently published book that describes the scene. Do you want to read it or shall I read it? Shall I read it? You read it. I'm going to read it. Read it with the dignity and the respect that I think this prose deserves. I will. I will. So this is, we're moving up here to the end of part one and I can think of no better way than to read something from Dominic's new book on Nelson. St Vincent met his friend's eye and his face was grave. Nelson must remember, he said,
这场任务关乎战争的命运，甚至可能关乎英国的存亡。但他没有感到丝毫恐惧，只有一种平静而坚定的决心。因此，多米尼克，在1798年5月8日，他通过直布罗陀海峡，向东驶入未知的世界。多么令人窒息的紧张感，多么难以置信的悬念。让我们休息一下，因为我都快喘不过气来了。麦当劳推出源源不断的惊喜好礼。送给你的宠物保姆彼得，以及负责铲除你家台阶积雪的克莱尔。
that once he sailed east of Gibraltar, he would pass beyond help. Most of the Mediterranean ports were loyal to France now. If he needed supplies or repairs, the only reliable harbor was at Naples. And thanks to Bonaparte, Naples' independence hung by a thread. A thread! Nelson nodded. He knew the risks, but he also knew the stakes.
还有当你花25美元购买麦当劳餐厅礼品卡时，就能获得免费巨无霸（Big Mac）或麦香鸡（McChicken）的优惠券，你也会收获这份惊喜。详情请参阅参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。有些东西需要付出大量心血才能成长，比如植物、头发、婴儿或你的储蓄。但是当你经营一家企业时，你手头要处理的事情已经够多的了。丰业银行（Scotiabank）的“企业适度储蓄账户”
Upon this mission depended the fate of the war, perhaps even the survival of Britain. But he felt no fear, just a quiet, calm resolve. And so Dominic on the 8th of May 1798, he sets off through the Straits of Gibraltar, east into the unknown. What tension, what an incredible tension. Let's take a break because I can hardly breathe. McDonald's has the gift that keeps giving. To Peter, your dog sitter, and Claire, who shovels your stairs.
可以帮你轻松实现储蓄增长。限时开设新账户，前六个月即可赚取高达4.65%的利息。在你不经意间，你的储蓄就会悄然增长。哦，这提醒了我，我需要理发了。须受条款及细则约束。截止日期为12月15日。利率为年利率，按日计算，并将根据账户余额而有所变动。访问 scotabank.com/rightsizesavings 了解完整详情。你知道野心最棒的地方在哪里吗？你看不到它。
And to you, when you spend $25 on McDonald's gift cards in restaurants, get a coupon for a free Big Mac or McChicken. See details at participating McDonald's restaurants. Some things require a lot of work to grow, like plants, hair, babies, or your savings. But when you run a business, you already have enough on your plate. Scotiabank's Right Size Savings for Business account
对您来说，在餐厅购买25美元的麦当劳礼品卡，即可获得免费巨无霸或麦香鸡的优惠券。详情请参阅参与活动的麦当劳餐厅。有些东西需要付出大量心血才能成长，比如植物、头发、婴儿或您的存款。但当您经营企业时，您的事务已经够多了。丰业银行的商业适度储蓄账户
can help you grow your savings with ease. For a limited time, open a new account and earn up to 4.65% interest for the first six months. Before you know it, your savings will grow without you even noticing. Ooh, which reminds me, I need a haircut. Conditions apply. Ends December 15th. Rate is annual, calculated daily, and will vary based on account balance. Visit scotabank.com slash rightsize savings for full details. You know what's great about ambition? You can't see it.
可以帮您轻松增加存款。在限时活动期间，开立新账户并在前六个月内赚取高达4.65%的利息。不知不觉中，您的存款就会在您甚至没有察觉的情况下增长。哦，这提醒了我，我需要理发了。受条款约束。12月15日截止。利率为年利率，按日计算，并根据账户余额而有所不同。访问 scotabank.com 顺杠 rightsize savings 了解完整详情。你知道野心最棒的地方是什么吗？你看不见它。
Some things look ambitious, but looks can be deceiving. For example, a runner could be training for a marathon or they could be late for the bus. You never know. Ambition is on the inside. So that road trip bucket list? Get after it. Drive your ambition. Mitsubishi Motors. So Dominic, we left our listeners on a moment of excruciating tension. Everything is literally hanging on a thread. Yeah, everything. So Nelson sailed east into the Mediterranean searching for this vast French fleet known as the Arbament. There is a massive burden on him, isn't there? Because as we've said, the ships that he's taking into the Mediterranean, searching for this vast French fleet known as the Arbament. There is a massive burden on him, isn't there?
有些事情看起来雄心勃勃，但外表往往会骗人。比如，一个跑步者可能是在为马拉松进行训练，也可能只是赶不上公交车。你永远猜不到。雄心是内在的。所以，那份公路旅行的愿望清单？去实现它吧。驱动你的雄心。三菱汽车。那么多米尼克，我们上一集把听众悬在了一个极度紧张的时刻。一切真的都命悬一线。是的，一切都是。所以纳尔逊向东驶入地中海，搜寻这支庞大的法国舰队，也就是所谓的“远征舰队”。他身上肩负着巨大的压力，不是吗？因为正如我们所说，他带入地中海的这些舰艇
Because as we've said, the ships that he's taking into the Mediterranean essentially is the naval reserve that would help Britain to block a French crossing of the Channel. Yeah, that's right. He can't afford to lose it. No, he can't. He does have something in his favour, which is the two ships that St Vincent has given him are really excellent ships. I mean, Nelson's delighted.
基本上是英国海军的后备力量，这些力量本可以帮助英国封锁法国人横渡英吉利海峡的通道。是的，没错。他输不起。不，他输不起。他确实有一点优势，那就是圣文森特给他的这两艘船真的是极好的船。我是说，纳尔逊非常高兴。
They are the Alexander and the Orion and these two captains are tremendous people. So the captain of the Alexander is a guy called Alexander Ball and he's from Gloucestershire. He's a squire son from Gloucestershire. He's a great reader and I'm delighted to report that he was inspired to go to sea by reading Robinson Crusoe. Well Dominic, could I just intervene at this point? I know that Daisy Christodaloo, wonderful educationalist who came on and did the history of exams for us, she I'm afraid argues that Robinson Crusoe is wholly irrelevant and hasn't had any impact on history at all. I know she's
它们是“亚历山大号”和“猎户座号”，这两位船长都是了不起的人物。“亚历山大号”的船长是一个叫亚历山大·鲍尔的人，他来自格洛斯特郡。他是格洛斯特郡一个乡绅的儿子。他博览群书，我很高兴地向大家报告，他读了《鲁滨逊漂流记》后才萌生了出海的念头。好吧，多米尼克，我能在此时打断一下吗？我知道黛西·克里斯托杜卢，这位曾来过我们节目并为我们讲述考试历史的杰出教育家，恐怕她认为《鲁滨逊漂流记》完全不相关，对历史没有任何影响。我知道她是
a listener and I hope that when she hears this, she will go away and reflect on her error. Yeah, because the entire career of Alexander Ball, an important player at the Battle of the Nile, probably somebody who had he not read Robinson Crusoe, Tom, you and I might be speaking French, imagine. Yes, and Daisy would be doing her educationalist stuff in French. So she should reflect on that. And also just to say, I mean, Nelson does really come to admire Alexander Ball, doesn't he? But I'm afraid to say that at one point Alexander Ball had disgraced
我们的听众，我希望当她听到这个时，她会去反思自己的错误。是的，因为亚历山大·鲍尔的整个职业生涯——尼罗河战役中的一个重要角色，汤姆，如果他没有读过《鲁滨逊漂流记》，你我今天可能都在说法语了，想象一下。是的，黛西也会用法语从事她的教育工作。所以她应该好好反思这一点。另外顺便说一句，纳尔逊确实非常钦佩亚历山大·鲍尔，对吧？但我遗憾地告诉大家，亚历山大·鲍尔曾一度因
himself by wearing epaulettes in the French style. And Nelson didn't approve of this and thought him a great coxcomb. That's terrible. Yeah, but it all ends well. They end up great pals, don't they? Yeah, which actually is not the case with the other man. The other man is also a brilliant captain. He's called James Sommaray and he's from Guernsey. I mean, these are funny characters, all of these captains, because this guy, Sommaray, is very sensitive and serious and is always sinking into black dogs kind of depressions.
穿着法式肩章而让自己蒙羞。纳尔逊并不赞成这一点，认为他是个十足的自大狂。太糟糕了。是的，但结局是好的。他们最终成了好朋友，不是吗？是的，不过另一个人的情况可就没这么好了。另一个人也是个出色的船长。他叫詹姆斯·萨马雷斯，来自根西岛。我的意思是，这些船长都是些有趣的人物，因为这家伙萨马雷斯非常敏感和严肃，总是陷入类似抑郁症的阴暗情绪中。
And he and Nelson have a slightly more tense relationship, I think it's fair to say. But Nelson knows that he's a brilliant captain. And that's what really matters. And that is what matters, exactly. Can he serve Britain? Yes, then he's good brilliant captain. And that's what really matters. And that is what matters exactly. Can he serve Britain? Yes. Then he's good. And their crews love them.
他和纳尔逊的关系稍微有些紧张，我想这样说挺公正的。但纳尔逊知道他是个出色的船长。这才是真正重要的。这确实是关键所在，完全没错。他能为英国效力吗？是的，那他就是个优秀的船长。这才是真正重要的。这确实是关键所在，完全没错。他能为英国效力吗？是的。那他就是个好样的。而且他们的船员都非常爱戴他们。
The three ships that he's got are as good as you could find anywhere in the world. Anyway, it's almost over before it begins this mission because just outside Toulon, they run into this massive storm. Nelson is a bit careless and heedless going into the storm because he's thinking only of the kind of political situation. So the Vanguard loses four of its masts and four sailors are swept overboard. And Nelson is very shaken by this. He writes to Fanny and he says, you know, I had thought myself one of the most fortunate
他手头的三艘船可以说是你在世界上任何地方都能找到的最好的船。不管怎样，这次任务还没开始就差点结束了，因为就在土伦外面，他们遭遇了一场巨大的风暴。纳尔逊在驶入风暴时有点粗心大意、满不在乎，因为他满脑子想的都是政治局势。结果“先锋号”失去了四根桅杆，四名水手被卷入了海中。纳尔逊对此深受震动。他写信给范妮，说道：“你知道的，我曾认为自己是最幸运的人之一
men to command such a squadron in such a place. My pride was too great, but the accidents which have happened to the vanguard were a just punishment for my vanity. I hope it has made me a better officer as I believe it has made me a better man." And actually, I thought this would be a nice moment to just stop and reflect on Nelson's character a bit because if you'd spoken to people in the Admiralty, you could have heard very disobliging reports of Nelson. People might have said, he's actually very vain, he's extremely annoying, he's difficult, he's prickly. He's a bit of a nightmare.
能在这样的地方指挥这样一支分舰队。我的傲傲气太盛了，但‘先锋号’遭遇的事故是对我虚荣心的正义惩罚。我希望这能让我成为一个更好的军官，正如我相信它让我成为了一个更好的人。”实际上，我以为这是一个很好的时刻，可以停下来稍微反思一下纳尔逊的性格，因为如果你跟海军部的那些人交谈，你会听到对纳尔逊非常不客气的评价。人们可能会说，他其实非常虚荣，极其烦人，很难相处，脾气暴躁。简直就是个噩梦。
But I think what redeems him is precisely this quality that is expressed in the letter to Fanny. He is reflective about his own faults. He genuinely is incredibly hardworking and he's self-improving and he's dedicated and resilient and all of these kinds of things. I mean, I think the thing about losing the mast, it's often said that Nelson, you know, his seamanship was incomparable. I don't think that's quite true. It's not really his qualities of seamanship that make him the extraordinary naval commander that he is. And he is capable
但我认为救赎他的正是这种在写给范妮的信中所表达的品质。他会反省自己的缺点。他真心实意地极其勤奋，不断自我完善，充满奉献精神和韧性，诸如此类。我的意思是，我觉得关于失去桅杆这件事，人们常说纳尔逊的航海术是无与伦比的。我认为这并不完全正确。让他成为一个非凡海军统帅的，其实并不是他的航海术。而且他确实能够
of errors like that. I think also the other thing, it's something that Patrick O'Brien famously alludes to when Jack Albury talks about meeting Nelson and there's this kind of passage about, you know, he doesn't need a great coat in the cold because he's a flame with seal for King and country. And Aubrey says, coming from anyone else, this would have sounded ludicrous, melodramatic, overwrought, but coming from him, you know, you felt, yeah, that's great. And there's something about that.
犯下这样的错误。我认为还有一点，帕特里克·奥布里安曾有一段著名的描写，讲的是杰克·奥布里谈到与纳尔逊会面时的一段话：你知道的，他在寒冷中不需要大衣，因为他心中对国王和国家的忠诚正烈火般燃烧。奥布里说，如果这话从别人嘴里说出来，听起来会显得荒谬、戏剧化、过度夸张，但从他嘴里说出来，你知道，你会觉得“没错，太棒了”。这其中确实有一种特质。
You know, the letter to Fanny, isn't there? I hope it has made me a better officer as I believe it has made me a better man. Yeah. Had he not been intensely burningly serious when he wrote that, it would have just seemed ludicrous. I think that's the thing, isn't it? Nelson is an extremely earnest man. I wouldn't credit him with too much of a sense of humour. He's not funny and he's certainly not self-deprecating. I don't think he would be a man who would enjoy jokes about the Royal Navy. He's so committed. He has this kind of moral earnestness. And actually, if you
你知道，就是写给范妮的那封信，不是吗？“我希望这能让我成为一个更好的军官，正如我相信它让我成为了一个更好的人。”是的。如果他写下这话时不是那么炽热而极度严肃，它就会显得荒谬。我想这就是关键所在，对吧？纳尔逊是一个极其严肃认真的人。我不会认为他有多少幽默感。他一点也不有趣，更绝对不会自嘲。我不认为他会是一个喜欢拿皇家海军开玩笑的人。他太投入了。他有着这种道德上的严肃性。实际上，如果你
think about our podcast that we did about the French Revolution, you know, moral earnestness is the character of the age, isn't it? It's absolutely a character of the age. I suppose it's the early age of romanticism, isn't it? And it's kind of part of that vibe. But I think he takes cliche and cranks it up to such a pitch that the cliche becomes kind of Homeric. Yes. Storm clouds of war hanging by a thread. And people thrill to it.
回想一下我们制作的关于法国大革命的播客，你知道，道德的严肃性正是那个时代的特征，不是吗？这绝对是那个时代的特征。我想这是早期浪漫主义时期，对吧？某种程度上符合那种氛围。但我认为他是把老套的词句推到了极致，以至于这些老套变得有了一种荷马史诗般的色彩。是的。战争的阴云密布，命悬一线。而人们为之热血沸腾。
People who would laugh if it came from anyone else find it utterly inspiring. But that's why I think the character that he most resembles in British history is Churchill. Churchill is exactly the same. I'm a great man. All that kind of rubbish. And then when Churchill says, you know, in the second world war, what's he say to the Tory MPs or something? If this island story of ours to end here, let it end when we're all choking in our own
如果这话出自别人之口，人们或许会付诸一笑，但在他身上却让人感到无比振奋。这就是为什么我认为他在英国历史中最像的人物是丘吉尔。丘吉尔完全一样。“我是个伟人。”诸如此类的废话。然后当丘吉尔在第二次世界大战中说出——他当时对保守党议员们说了什么？——如果我们的这段岛屿故事要在此终结，那就让我们在泥土中窒息于自己的
blood on the ground. I mean, if somebody says that in real life, if Theo said that about the rest is history, we'd just laugh. Keir Starmer. Yes. Keir Starmer would never say that in a million years. But I think there's a... What's the histrionic quality that is elevated to the operatic, you might say?
鲜血中时结束吧。我的意思是，如果有人在现实生活中这么说，如果西奥对《历史的歇息》说这种话，我们只会哈哈大笑。斯塔默。是的。基尔·斯塔默绝不可能在一百万年里说出这种话。但我认为有一种……怎么说，那种被提升到可以说是歌剧般高度的戏剧化特质？
Exactly. The operatic quality of Nelson, I think is exactly right. I'm amazed. Have there not been operas about Nelson? There must have been. There should be. I mean, it's quite a lot of music as we may see in the second part of our series. Yes. But not an opera, I think. So anyway, they have not been wrecked. So they continue and they approach Toulon. It is clear the French are long gone from Toulon. So now basically they're looking for a needle in the haystack.
没错。纳尔逊身上那种歌剧般的特质，我觉得形容得太贴切了。我很震惊。难道没有关于纳尔逊的歌剧吗？肯定有过的。应该有。我的意思是，正如我们在本系列第二部分中看到的，里面有相当多的音乐。是的。但我想还没有歌剧。总之，他们没有遇难。所以他们继续前行，逼近土伦。很明显，法国人离开土伦已经很久了。所以现在他们基本上是在大海捞针。
They are. I mean, the huge expanse of the Mediterranean to find this fleet is going to be really tough. They then spot a sort of sail. It's a brig and it's come from St. Vincent. He has sent, of all people, Hardy, Thomas Masterman Hardy, who's now a Commodore. And Hardy says, we've heard intelligence, we have news. This enormous fleet has been spotted heading towards Italy, at least a dozen ships to the
确实如此。地中海地域辽阔，要在其中找到这支舰队实在是难上加难。随后，他们发现了一艘帆船的踪影。那是一艘来自圣文森特的双桅横帆船。他派出的不是别人，正是托马斯·马斯特曼·哈迪，他现在已经是一名准将了。哈迪说：“我们听到了情报，有了消息。这支庞大的舰队被发现正驶向意大利，至少有十多艘战列舰，数百艘运输船。命令变了。我们要你拦截这支舰队，并且我们会派增援来协助你。”所以你的老朋友、因特内里费岛之战而闻名的托马斯·特鲁布里奇正在赶来。
line, hundreds of transports. The orders have changed. We want you to intercept this fleet and we will be sending reinforcements for you to do this. So your old mate, Thomas Trubridge of Tenerife fame is on his way. Hates the French. He does hate the French with a passion with 11 more ships. And you know, go for it now.
他痛恨法国人。他确实对法国人恨之入骨，这次还带了另外11艘船。你知道的，现在就放手大干吧。这是一场旨在彻底消灭敌人的战役。因此，他被告知英国海军的精英正在向他增援。但这里有一个巨大的不利因素，那就是缺乏巡洋舰——这种在前一年开始建造、专为速度而设计的船只。很显然，如果你在搜寻一支舰队，巡洋舰将是理想的选择。圣文森特其实派给了纳尔逊九艘这样的巡洋舰，但由于种种原因，只有一艘到达了他身边。所以在接下来的几周里，这将成为纳尔逊真正的难题，因为他 simplemente 缺乏找到这支远征军所需的资源。
This is a campaign of annihilation. And so he's told that he's being sent the elite of the Navy of England. But there is one big drawback, which is that there's a lack of cruisers, an order of ship that had begun to be constructed the previous year and are designed for speed. And obviously they would be ideal if you're looking for a fleet. And St Vincent actually sends Nelson nine of these cruisers, but for kind of concatenation of reasons, only one reaches him. And so this will be a real problem for Nelson over the next few weeks because he just lacks the resources necessary to find an expedition.
所以希纳有14艘战舰，正如你所说汤姆，它们是皇家海军的精锐。他还拥有三个月的补给：面包、橘子、牛肉以及所有这些物资。活生生的公牛。活生生的公牛。我们有乘坐“卡洛登号”的特鲁布里奇，有乘坐“柏勒罗丰号”的亨利·德斯泰·德比，有乘坐“歌利亚号”的托马斯·弗利。这些都是皇家海军的顶尖精锐。他们真的是达到了纳尔逊那种水平的人。你知道的，是在纪律严明、训练有素的舰船上的杰出指挥官。
Yeah. So Hina has 14 fighting ships and they are, as you said Tom, they're the elite of the Royal Navy. And he's also got supplies for three months. So bread and oranges and beef and all that stuff. Literal bullocks. Literal bullocks. We have Truebridge in the Culloden, we have henry d'estair derby in the bellerophon, thomas foley in goliath. these are the cream of the crop of the royal navy. these are people at nelson's level really. you know, brilliant commanders in extremely well disciplined, well trained ships.
就像阿金库尔战役中英国贵族的精锐一样，不是吗？嗯，这就是那个比喻，不是吗？这确实就是那个比喻，因为我们在第一集里就谈到过，纳尔逊在学校里显然一定很喜欢莎士比亚，因为他对亨利五世以及“兄弟连”的概念有着绝对的执着。而现在，我们之所以提到所有人，是因为这就是兄弟连。他有着一种浪漫的情怀，认为这就像是亚历山大大帝的同伴，或是阿金库尔战役前亨利五世的帕拉丁骑士。这些人将在最黑暗的时刻并肩作战，肩并肩，所有这些纳尔逊深信不疑的事情。而且据说在纳尔逊手下，从来没有哪位海军上将像他那样平易近人、乐于倾听其他
so like the cream of the english peerage at the battle of ashencourt, don't they Well, that's the comparison, isn't it? That is the comparison, because we talked in the very first episode about how Nelson clearly must have loved Shakespeare at school because he's got this absolute fixation on Henry V and on the idea of the band of brothers. And this now, the reason we've mentioned all these people is that this is the band of brothers. He has this romantic is that this is the band of brothers. He has this romantic yearning, I guess, that these are like, you know, Alexander the Great's companions or Henry V's paladins before Agincourt. These are the people who will stand together in the darkest hour, you know, shoulder to shoulder, all of this kind of thing, which Nelson absolutely believes in. And it is said of Nelson that there was never an Admiral who was more open to being approached by his fellow
船长的意见。是的，因为他的工作方式是会邀请他们过来吃晚饭之类的。这就是“纳尔逊的触觉”。没错，“纳尔逊的触觉”——在那边吃着斑点狗布丁、牛排派或者别的什么。他们会没完没了地讨论战术和计划。他非常坦诚、非常慷慨，这在当时很不寻常。是的。当然，这里依然存在等级制度，他们也确实尊重他，但以当时的标准来看，他要没那么严苛。他想听听他们的想法，而且显而易见，他们有许多事情要讨论，因为他们不知道这支远征舰队究竟开往何方，他们必须设法弄清楚，不是吗？
captains. Yeah, because his way of working is he will have them over won't he for dinner and stuff. A touch of Nelson. Exactly, the Nelson touch over there kind of spotted dog and kind of steak pudding or whatever. They will talk on and on about the tactics and the plan. He's very open and very generous, which is unusual. Yeah. I mean, obviously there is a hierarchy and they do defer to him, but by the standards of the time he's much less strict. He wants to hear what they've got to say and obviously they have a lot to discuss because they don't know where this armament is heading and they've got to try and work it out, haven't they? Exactly. So here are the options. It
没错。所以目前的选项有这些。它很可能是驶往意大利南部，以便彻底消灭那不勒斯王国。它也可能前往希腊。希腊是奥斯曼帝国的一部分，但奥斯曼帝国的好多地方感觉都像是熟透了的果子，随时可以采摘。所以它也可能是去希腊。甚至还有人谈到君士坦丁堡。还有人谈到去更远的地方，向东南方向前往埃及。你刚才提到了埃及。有一些传言称，法国人一直在集结学者和科学家，他们脑子里在酝酿着某种疯狂的行动。不过这太异想天开了，不是吗？
could well be heading for southern Italy to basically snuff out the kingdom of Naples. It could head to Greece. Greece is part of the Ottoman Empire, but a lot of the Ottoman Empire feels like it's ripe for the plucking. So it could be going to Greece. It does talk of Constantinople. There is also talk of going further east, going southeast towards Egypt. You mentioned Egypt earlier. There are some rumors that the French have been lining up scholars and scientists and they've got some crazy operation in mind. Very far-fetched though, isn't it?
太异想天开了。一路去到埃及？我的意思是，太不可能了。我的意思是，甚至还有传言说法国人已经派特工去了印度，那里正在酝酿着什么，也许是对东印度公司的攻击。我的意思是，这是一个疯狂的梦想，就像亚历山大大帝的梦想一样疯狂。我的意思是，简直完全不合情理。没错，汤姆。
Very far-fetched. To go all the way to Egypt? I mean, very unlikely. I mean, there are even rumors that the French have dispatched agents to India and that there is something brewing, perhaps an attack on the East India Company. I mean, it's a dream mad in the way that Alexander the Great's dreams were mad. I mean, just wholly implausible. Exactly, Tom.
没错。所以英国国内的每个人都在关注这件事。我的意思是，他们落后了好几个星期，隔着一层来关注。所以他们看着报纸，心中充满了无比的紧张，你知道的，范妮在报纸上焦急地搜寻关于她丈夫的报道，海军部的人们无时无刻不在等待：这支远征舰队究竟开往何方？其中一个人写道，一个海军部官员写道：“在波拿巴舰队的成功或毁灭之上，一个具有重大意义的事件可能会决定，不仅是我们，而是全欧洲的命运。”太惊人了。
Exactly. So everybody back home in Britain is following this. I mean, they're following us at weeks behind at one remove. So they're reading the newspapers and there is a sort of an immense nervousness, you know, Fanny pouring over the papers for reports of her husband, the people at the Admiralty waiting all the time, where is this armament heading? One of them writes, an Admiralty official writes, on the success or destruction of Bonaparte's
但你知道，他们找不到它。它似乎凭空消失了。约翰·萨格登在他那部无与伦比的纳尔逊传记中对这一情况做出了绝妙的总结。他写道：“神秘的是，没有人听到过关于法国人的可靠消息。他们似乎成了幻影，能够随心所欲地实体化和虚无化。”这简直就像科幻小说里的情节。某种带有隐形护盾的外星舰队之类的。
fleet, an event of great moment, not to us alone, but to all Europe may depend. Amazing. But you know, they can't find it. It seems to have vanished into the air. And John Sugden in his incomparable biography of Nelson sums it up gloriously. So he writes, mysteriously, no one had heard a reliable word about the French. They seem to be phantasms capable of materializing and dematerializing at their pleasure. It's like something out of science fiction. A kind of alien fleet with invisibility shields or something.
情况确实如此，因为地中海是一百万平方英里的海洋，无论他们走到哪里，都能听到传言，但没有什么是确定的。他们去了那不勒斯，特鲁布里奇上岸去与英国驻那不勒斯特使威廉·汉密尔顿爵士协商。他们在那里呆了两个小时，然后回到船上说：“汉密尔顿确信无疑。他们正开往西西里。”他们向南穿过墨西拿海峡，驶过地平线上冒着烟的埃特纳火山。他们发现了另一艘双桅横帆船。这艘船的船长说：“我听到过法国国旗在马耳他上空飘扬的报告，所以他们占领了马耳他。”
That's exactly what it is because the Mediterranean is a million square miles of sea and wherever they go, they hear rumors, but nothing's certain. They go to Naples and Truebridge goes ashore to consult with the British envoy in Naples, Sir William Hamilton. They go to Naples and Truebridge goes ashore to consult with the British envoy in Naples, Sir William Hamilton. He's there for two hours, then he comes back to the ship and he says, Hamilton is sure of it. They're heading for Sicily. They sail south through the Straits of Messina, past Etna, smoking on the horizon. They spot another brig. And the captain of this brig says, I've heard reports of French flags flying over Malta, but so they've taken Malta.
这至关重要，不是吗？因为马耳他地处地中海东半部和西半部的枢纽。所以谁控制了马耳他，基本上就控制了地中海海上航线赖以运转的转轴。我刚才的比喻有点混淆了，我想，但你明白我的意思。不，我认为这是一个很有力的描述。谢谢你，多米尼克。所以波拿巴已经前行了。他已经驶过了马耳他、希腊、君士坦丁堡、埃及。
And that's crucial, isn't it? Because Malta is the pivot between the eastern and the western half of the Mediterranean. So whoever controls Malta essentially controls the hinge on which sea routes through the Mediterranean operate. Slightly mixing my metaphors there, I think, but you know what I mean. No, I think it's a powerful description. Thank you, Dominic. So Bonaparte has moved on. He's gone past Malta, Greece, Constantinople, Egypt.
他为什么要去埃及？我的意思是，这一定是在纳尔逊脑海中盘旋的问题。埃及在名义上是奥斯曼帝国的一个省，但在实际上几个世纪以来一直由马木路克统治。所以他们是奥斯曼帝国突厥奴隶士兵的后代。在纸面上，马木路克是中立的。但如果波拿巴能拿下埃及，那基本上就等于让他控制了整个东南地中海。这也意味着它能为他提供红海上的港口，法军可以从那里
Why would he make for Egypt? I mean, this is the question that must be in Nelson's mind. Egypt is technically a province of the Ottoman Empire, but in practice it has been run for centuries by the Mamluks. So they're the descendants of the Turkic slave soldiers of the Ottomans. On paper, the Mamluks are neutral. But if Bonaparte could get Egypt, that basically gives him the whole of the south eastern Mediterranean. And it also means it gives him ports on the Red Sea from which the French could
向东出击，将英国对印度的贸易席卷一空。所以也许那些关于法国特工在东方穿梭于集市的报道是真的。他们精通各种语言。没错。也许他们精通易容伪装。也许这其中真的有些名堂。这非常具有约翰·巴金风格的间谍片色彩。
strike East to hoover up the British trade with India. So maybe that stuff, those reports about French agents out there in the East moving through the bazaars. Their mastery of tongues. Exactly. Maybe the mastery of disguise. Maybe there's something in it. It's very green mantle.
这非常像约翰·巴金以及诸如此类的风格，不是吗？所以纳尔逊召开了这场至关重要的会议。他邀请了他最亲近的四位船长——特鲁布里奇、鲍尔、萨马雷斯和德比登上“先锋号”。他说：“好了，我们眼下有三种可能的行动方案。我们可以进攻马耳他，把法军守军赶出去，试着重新夺回马耳他。但这意味着，你知道的，远征舰队一直在四处航行，而我们，你知道的，根本不知道它在做什么。我们可以掉头返回西西里和那不勒斯，以防这一切都只是个计谋，而这正是法国人的意图。或者我们可以向南转向埃及。”他对其他船长说，我引述原话：“如果远征舰队去了亚历山大港并在那里安全靠岸，我们在印度的领地可能就丢了。你们觉得我们最好向那个地方发起冲锋吗？”然后他分发——这是一个非常戏剧性的时刻。太棒了。是的。四张纸。
It's very John Buck and all this, isn't it? So Nelson has this crucial conference. He invites the four captains to whom he's closest. That is Truebridge, Ball, Sommaray and Derby aboard the Vanguard. And he says, right, we have three possible courses of action here. We could attack Malta, turf out the French garrison and try to retake Malta. But that means, you know, the armament is sailing around and we've, you know, we don't know what it's doing. We could head back towards Sicily and Naples in case this is all to ruse and that's what the
他说：“你们每一个人把答案写在这张纸上。”然后他们一个接一个地写下了同一个词：亚历山大港。这是一个绝妙的时刻。于是他们向亚历山大港进发，顺风行船，速度极快，而他们自己却一无所知。但在他们前进的同时，他们危险地与法国远征舰队擦肩而过。我的意思是，近得难以置信。也许再往南开几英里，他们就能看见它了。不管怎样，他们继续前行，一周后的6月29日，他们驶入了亚历山大港，这座地中海沿岸最浪漫、最具历史底蕴的城市之一。我的意思是，想象一下吧。
French have in mind. Or we could turn south towards Egypt. And he says to the other captains, and I quote, should the armament be gone to Alexandria and get safe there, our possessions in India are probably lost. Do you think we had better push for that place? And then he hands out, it's very kind of dramatic moment. Brilliant. Yeah. Four pieces of paper.
他们自己正身处这个时代伟大的戏剧之中，但他们面对的背景是如此完美，无以复加。嗯，我们之前已经提到过亚历山大，不是吗？我的意思是，这是由亚历山大大帝建立的。这里是安东尼和克利奥帕特拉厮混过的地方。它是基督教和伊斯兰教最伟大的城市之一。我的意思是，太不可思议了。对于一个把自己视作歌剧人物、伟大情节剧英雄的人来说，
And he says, each of you write your answer on this piece of paper. And one by one, they write the same word, Alexandria. It's a brilliant moment. So off to Alexandria, they head and the wind is behind them and they make tremendous speed and they don't know it. But as they're heading, they pass perilously close to the French armament. I mean, unbelievably close. Maybe a couple further miles south and they would have seen it. But anyway, on they go and a week later on the 29th of June, they sail into Alexandria, one of the most romantic, historic cities on the whole of the Mediterranean. I mean, imagine that.
这是多么美妙的时刻啊！但要做一个伟大情节剧的英雄，你可不想让自己看起来像个傻瓜。而纳尔逊此时看起来就像个傻瓜，因为根本没有法国人的影子。他们猜错了。他们抵达了，却什么也没有。他派哈迪上岸去跟当地人交谈，哈迪回来后说：“什么也没有，没有法国人的踪影。也没有任何关于法国人的报告。”
They are in the great drama of the age themselves, but they're against a backdrop that is, that couldn't be better. Well, we've already mentioned Alexander, haven't we? I mean, this is founded by Alexander the Great. It's where Anthony Cleopatra hung out. It's one of the great cities of Christianity and Islam. I mean, incredible. For somebody who conceives of himself as an operatic figure, as the hero of a great melodrama,
我的意思是，对纳尔逊来说这是多么毁灭性的时刻啊。令人崩溃。因为时间紧迫。他的补给不多了，而在一个犹如法国湖泊的海域里获取补给是如此困难，他深知失去的每一天都是法国人可能在围攻君士坦丁堡、围攻那不勒斯的一天，谁知道呢？他犯下了可怕的错误，他们可能正前往君士坦丁堡或那不勒斯，他必须赶快行动。所以在第二天，即30号，他说：“我们不能在亚历山大港浪费更多时间了。我们必须离开，继续
what a moment. But to be a hero of a great melodrama, you don't want to look like an idiot. And Nelson looks like an idiot because there's no sign of the French. They've called it wrong. They arrive and there's nothing. He sends Hardy ashore to talk to the locals and Hardy comes back and he says, nothing, no sign of the French. There's been no reports of the French.
搜寻工作。”于是他们起航了。而难以置信的是，就在一天零一个小时之后，波拿巴驶入了亚历山大港。这当然是世界历史上最具转折意义的时刻之一。这是一个你可以说欧洲帝国主义时代真正拉开帷幕的时刻。也许从全球范围来看，19世纪就是从这里开始的。我们之前已经做过一集关于它的节目了，不是吗？我们做过一集关于拿破仑在埃及的节目。这是一个不可思议的故事。对拿破仑而言，进攻埃及就是对英国的攻击。所以他将这次远征描述为英国军团的左翼。为了彻底摧毁英国，我们必须占领埃及，因为这样他们就能扼杀英国对印度的贸易，并可能
I mean, what a devastating moment for Nelson. Crushing. Because time is of the essence. He doesn't have that many supplies and getting supplies in what is a French lake is so difficult and he knows that every day lost is a day that the French could be laying siege to Constantinople, laying siege to Naples, who knows? He has made a terrible mistake and they're probably heading to either Constantinople or Naples and he must hurry. So the very next day, the 30th, he says, we're not waiting any more time in Alexandria. We have to get out and get on
赢得印度。这就是拿破仑打击英国的思路。但这远不止于此。成为一个新亚历山大的幻想正在拿破仑的脑海中盘旋。在他的船舱里，有一个巨大的书架，摆满了书籍——你知道的，那些他在童年时期就深爱的希腊和罗马历史的书籍。他一直在读这些书来激励自己。他真把自己当成了新的亚历山大大帝。“我看到自己骑在大象上向亚洲行进，头上裹着头巾，手里拿着一本我自己为了适应需要而编写的新《古兰经》。”所以我们之前谈到纳尔逊具有戏剧性和歌剧化。我的意思是，拿破仑完全是另一个量级的。但除此之外，这也是一次将向欧洲人揭示
with the hunt and they make sale. And unbelievable, one day and one hour later, Bonaparte sales into Alexandria. And this of course is one of the pivotal moments in world history. It's a moment where you could say the age of European imperialism really begins. This is where the 19th century perhaps in global terms starts. And we have already done an episode on it, haven't we? We did an episode on Napoleon in Egypt. And it's an incredible story. So for Napoleon, attacking Egypt is an attack on Britain. So he describes that expedition as being the left wing of the army of England. To destroy England thoroughly, we must seize Egypt because then they can throttle Britain's trade with India and maybe
埃及真实面貌的远征。埃及作为一个伊斯兰国家，可以像学者研究植物、野生动物或其他东西那样去被研究。当然，它也是法老历史的伟大中心。这就是为什么拿破仑要带上学者们同行的原因。这不仅是一次帝国的征服，也是启蒙运动对世界研究的主权宣示。所以你完全可以说这也是一个帝国项目。因此，他带去了成群的学者、哲学家。他带去了一台从梵蒂冈顺来的印刷机，能够用拉丁文、阿拉伯文和叙利亚文印刷。他甚至还带了一个热气球。我的意思是，这是一个非凡的故事。如果你对此感兴趣，却没有听过我们在大约三年前左右做过的那期节目的话，
win India. That's the way Napoleon thinks to get at Britain. But it's also much more than that. The fantasy of being a new Alexander is playing in Napoleon's mind. In his cabin, he has a huge library full of books, you know, the books of Greek and Roman history that he had so loved as a boy. He's reading them through to inspire him. He literally sees himself as the new Alexander the Great. So I saw myself marching to Asia mounted on an elephant, a turban on my head and in my hand a new Quran that I would have composed to suit my needs. So we talked about Nelson being historyionic and operatic. I mean, Napoleon is in a different order. But there is also the fact that this is an expedition that will open the eyes of Europe
一定要去听听看。当然。我可能稍微有些淡化了这次军事行动的规模。我的意思是，他带了4万名士兵。他有2万名水手。这是一次规模巨大的两栖远征。而且非常成功，因为他花了三周时间，在登陆三周后，他在金字塔战役中粉碎了马木路克的军队。是的。
to the reality of Egypt. Egypt as an Islamic country that can be studied in the way that savants might study plants or wildlife or whatever. But also, of course, the great centre of pharaonic history. And this is why Napoleon is taking Savants with him. It's an expedition not just of imperial conquest, but of the enlightenment laying claim to the study of the world. And so you might well say that that's also an imperial project. So he takes teams of Savants with him, philosophers. He takes a printing press that he'd nicked from the Vatican, which can print in Latin, in Arabic and Syriac. And he even takes a hot air balloon. I mean, it is an extraordinary story. And if you have any interest in it and haven't heard the episode that we did
士兵们。那是怎么说的？“4000年的历史在俯视着你们。”没错。大意如此的话。我的意思是，他自己，当然，拿破仑也把自己看作是一个歌剧般的人物。我的意思是，这其实就是这个故事的乐趣所在，我想不出历史上有多少时刻能与之真正匹敌，每个人都
when about three years ago, I think something like that. Do listen to that. Absolutely. I slightly perhaps underplayed the military dimensions of this. I mean, so he's brought 40,000 soldiers. He's got 20,000 sailors. This is an enormous amphibious expedition. And very successful because it takes him three weeks and three weeks after landing. He smashes the Mamluks army at the battle of the pyramids. Yes.
意识到自己正在最大的舞台上扮演一个角色。在7月24日，他开入开罗。他现在成了埃及的主人。所以拿破仑似乎已经赢了。与此同时，纳尔逊一直在向东航行，仍在搜寻这支舰队。他沿土伦海岸巡航，然后调头向东驶向西西里。此时，他的补给——水果和水——快要耗尽了。他们掉头驶回西西里。此时，他的补给——水果和水——快要耗尽了。他们掉头驶回西西里，
Soldiers. What is it? Something 4,000 years of history gazed down upon you. Exactly. Words to that day. I mean, he too, of course, Napoleon too regards himself as an operatic figure. And I mean, that's the joy of this story, actually. I can't think of many moments in history that really match it, where everybody is
在叙拉古停了下来。在这里，他们得到了来自那不勒斯的新情报。法国人没有经过那不勒斯。他们没有进入西地中海。他们没有在意大利登陆。他们绝对是去东方了。同样，大概也正是在这个时候，纳尔逊邀请他的船长们共进晚餐，他说：“你知道的，时间不多了，但我认为我们已经清晰地缩小了范围。他们一定在东方的某个地方。而当我们找到他们时，我们将这样做。”这不是霍瑟姆海军上将。
conscious of that they're playing a part on the greatest stage of all. And on the 24th of July, he marches into Cairo. He is now the master of Egypt. So Napoleon, it seems has won. Now, meanwhile, Nelson has been sailing East, still searching for this fleet. He cruised along the coast of Turkey, and then he turned back East towards Sicily. At this point, he's running out of supplies, fruit and water. They head back towards Sicily. They stop point, he's running out of supplies, fruit and water. They head back towards Sicily,
这不是封锁。我们要进攻他们。直接冲向他们。太棒了。把他们从大洋上彻底消灭。在当时这很不寻常，对吧？我们在之前的节目里讨论过。我想，这正变得越来越不寻常。是的。纳尔逊借鉴了洛克船长、胡德海军上将以及所有这些曾是他的伟大赞助人的人的做法。圣文森特就这样做过。圣文森特就这样做过。但他
they stop at Syracuse. Here, they get new intelligence from Naples. The French have not passed Naples. They have not gone through into the Western Mediterranean. They have not landed in Italy. They've definitely gone east. Again, it's probably about this point that Nelson has his captains for dinner and he says, you know, time is running out, but I think we've clearly narrowed down. They must be somewhere out there in the East. And when we find them, this is what we will do. It's not Admiral Hotham.
说：“听着，这就是我们要做的。这是孤注一掷。我们冒一切风险。我们直接上。”一种极具侵略性的战略。而目标是一场歼灭战，不是吗？如果他们能消灭法国舰队，那么拿破仑在陆地上的军事胜利将毫无意义。没错。他们将被困在那里。因此，这是一个拥有总体计划，但在计划内部又给予一定程度的自主权和发挥主观能动性的战略。他信任他的船长们，他的船长们也欣喜若狂。四天后，他们再次起航。他们现在时刻在进行火炮演习。但当然，他们仍然不知道他在哪里，而当拿破仑渴望战斗时，由于时间如此紧迫，紧张情绪正在不断升级。
It's not a blockade. Well, we attack them. We go straight at them. Amazing. And wipe them off the face of the sea. And this is unusual at the time, right? We talked in previous episodes. Becoming less unusual, I think. Yes. Nelson is drawing on Captain Locker and Admiral Hood and all of these people who have been his great patrons. St Vincent had done it. St Vincent had done it. But he
他们收到了来自伦敦的信件，纳尔逊打开其中一封，一位外交官对他说：“全欧洲的眼睛都在看着你。你知道的，你现在必须这么做。”他们返回希腊。他们到达了一个叫做科罗尼的地方，位于伯罗奔尼撒半岛的最南端。特鲁布里奇上岸打听消息，几小时内他就回来了，满心欢喜地带来了一个消息。他说奥斯曼总督表示他得到了确切的证实。他们果然在亚历山大港。于是纳尔逊再次向南掉头，扬起风帆借风前行。他彻夜难眠。
says, look, this is what we're doing. It is all or nothing. We risk everything. We just go for it. An aggressive strategy. And the aim is a battle of annihilation, isn't it? If they can wipe out the French fleet, then Napoleon's military victory on land will count for nothing. Exactly. They'll be stranded there. So a strategy in which we have an overall plan, but within that, you have a degree of discretion and to use your initiative. I he trusts his captains his captains are delighted and after four days they set off again They are drilling now with their guns all the time But of course they still don't know where he is when Napoleon is itching for battle There is a real sense of mounting tension now because time is so short
他在后甲板上踱来踱去，他们一路急行。8月1日早上10点，“亚历山大号”上的瞭望员在远处的地平线上发现了带有标志性的灰色陆地模糊轮廓。一个小时左右，消息传到了纳尔逊耳中。法国三色旗在亚历山大港上空飘扬。港口里有法国的运输船，空空如也。法军已经登陆并继续前进。埃及陷落了。纳尔逊的一位船长后来回忆说，在那一刻他们感到“彻底绝望，士气低落”。他们追逐法国人几百英里，把舰船和水手逼到了极限，结果却失败了。
They get letters from London and Elton opens one of them and a diplomat says to him the eyes of all Europe are upon you You know, you've got to do this now. They return to Greece. They reach a place called Koroni at the very bottom tip of the Peloponnese. And Troubridge goes ashore to find information and he comes back within hours and he's bursting with news. He says the Ottoman governor says he has had definite confirmation. They are in Alexandria after all. So again, Nelson turns south and he spreads his sails to catch the wind. He can't sleep.
法国人已经在埃及站稳了脚跟。当然，这里也存在一种风险，不是吗？那就是这支舰队已经去了更安全的地方。没错。这是仅存的一点安慰，是救赎的唯一可能。最后一线希望。最后一线希望，没错，那就是如果他们能找到那支法国舰队，说不定他们的法国海军上将可能已经把舰队开下了海岸，停泊在离开罗更近的一个港口里。如果他们能找到并消灭它，那么波拿巴所做的一切都将化为乌有，因为法军将陷入绝境，补给断绝，他的征服也将化为过眼云烟。
He's pacing the quarterdeck and they rush and they rush. At 10 a.m. on the 1st of August, the lookout on the Alexander spies in the horizon, the kind of telltale gray blur of land. And within an hour or so, news comes to Nelson. There are French tricolor flags flying over Alexandria. There are French transports in the harbor, empty. The French army has landed and has moved on. Egypt has fallen. And one of Nelson's captains said later that at that moment they felt quote, utterly hopeless and out of spirits. They've been pursuing the French for hundreds of miles. They've pushed their ships and their men to the limit and they have failed.
多米尼克，顺便说一句，法国海军的高层其实是想要撤退的。他们本想撤退到爱奥尼亚群岛，但拿破仑拒绝了。这是不是一个致命的失误，我们在下一集中就会揭晓。所以纳尔逊对“热诚号”和“歌利亚号”的船长说：“快点沿海岸向东搜寻，花不了多长时间。从海图上我们知道，阿布吉尔湾有一个深水港，离尼罗河口很近。沿海岸去看看吧。”他们向东驶去，那天下午两点，他们接近了
The French have got the foothold in Egypt they wanted. And of course there's the risk isn't there, that the fleet will have gone somewhere safer. Exactly. That's the one crumb of consolation, the one possibility of redemption. The one flickering of hope. The last flicker of hope exactly is if they can find that French fleet, just maybe their French Admiral may have taken the fleet down the coast and parked it in a harbor closer to Cairo. If they can get it and destroy it, then everything Bonaparte would have done would be for nothing because the French army will be stranded and cut off from supplies and his conquests will just be ephemeral.
尼罗河三角洲。下午两点半，一名16岁的见习水手乔治·埃利奥特——当然不是那个小说家。在“歌利亚号”最高的横桁上举着望远镜向远方眺望，然后他在远处看到了某种东西。这就像是《怒海争锋》里的场景。13艘战列舰、4艘巡洋舰、5艘双桅横帆船和炮舰，它们的法国国旗在微风中飘扬。汤姆，他们找到他们了。多么惊心动魄的悬念。在本季的最后一集中，我们将讲述接下来发生的故事：尼罗河战役。如果你实在等不及，可以前往
And Domny, just say that the French high command in the navy had wanted to withdraw. They'd wanted to withdraw to the Ionian Islands, but Napoleon has said no. And it's, well, we'll find out in the next episode, whether it's a fateful mistake or not. So Nelson says to the captains of the Zealots and the Goliath, just quickly head east along the coast, it won't take long. We know from our charts, there's a deep harbor at Abu Kier Bay, which is quite close to the mouth of the Nile. Just have a look down along the coast, they go east and at two o'clock that afternoon, they approached
therestlesshistory.com加入俱乐部。当然，如果你已经是订阅者，就像纳尔逊一样，直接加入吧，不要迟疑。英国期待大家各尽其责。再见。["星条旗永不落"] 汤姆，我们有一个难以置信的振奋人心的好消息要和听众分享，对吧？我们当然有，多米尼克。又到了每年的这个时候
the Delta of the Nile and at 2.30 a midshipman, 16 years old, George Eliot. Not the novelist obviously. It's in the, not the novelist, is on the highest yards of the Goliath with a telescope to his eye and then he sees something in the distance. It's like the scene from Master and Commander. 13 ships of the line, four frigates, five briggs and bomb vessels, their French flags fluttering in the breeze. Tom, they have found them. What a cliffhanger. And in the final episode of this season, we will tell the story of what happens next. The Battle of the Nile. And if you just can't wait, then you can head
你得为生命中最挚爱的人寻找那份完美的礼物，而我们非常高兴能帮你迎接这个挑战。我们在此宣布推出《历史的歇息》周边商品。是的，你现在可以拥有真正的一段历史了。我们真的推出了衬衫、马克杯、手机壳、笔记本，应有尽有，正赶上圣诞节，这场景简直难以置信，汤姆！因为这些可不仅仅是普通的衬衫和马克杯，汤姆，这些都是独家设计的《历史的歇息》图案，它们是专门为了超越《历史的政治》团队的朋友们在他们的英格兰巡回演出中一直在兜售的罗里和阿拉斯泰尔T恤而设计的。
to therestlesshistory.com to join the club. Obviously, if you're already a subscriber, like Nelson, go straight in. don't delay. England expects. Goodbye. ["The Star-Spangled Banner"] Now, Tom, we have something unbelievably exciting to share with our listeners, don't we? Absolutely we do, Dominic. It's that time of year again
没错，多米尼克，历史永远压倒政治。而我们的新周边绝对是送给任何历史迷的完美礼物，无论他们是节目的老朋友，还是——我们敢这么说吗——还没成为节目朋友的人。对。我的意思是，这真是一个令人难以置信的狡猾把戏，对吧？确实如此。因为如果你是节目的忠实朋友，你可以买一件骄傲地宣告你立场的T恤。如果你还在犹豫——你知道你是谁——那你也可以买一件“还不是节目的朋友”版本的T恤。所以你可以用一件T恤或连帽衫来表明你的立场。
when you've got to find that perfect gift for the loved one in your life and we are thrilled to help you with that challenge. We are announcing the launch of the Rest Is History merchandise. Yes, you can now own a piece of history literally. We've literally got shirts mugs phone cases notebooks so much just in time for Christmas unbelievable scenes Tom because these aren't just any shirts and mugs Tom these are exclusive Rest is history designs and they have been designed specifically to outdo the Rory and Alastair t-shirts that our friends on the Rest is Politics team have been flogging on their tour of England that they've done.
这绝对是派对上的破冰神器。你会怎么说？“你不知道《历史的歇息》吗？好吧，让我来告诉你。”当你和别人聊起戈登将军、信鸽、威廉二世或者其他什么人时，你身上穿着最完美的衬衫。所以可能性是无限的。多米尼克，还有更多好东西。
That's right Dominic, history will always trump politics. And our new merch truly is the perfect gift for any history fan, whether they're a friend of the show or dare we say, someone who's not yet a friend of the show. Yeah. I mean, this is an unbelievably cunning wheeze, isn't it? Really is. Because if you're a loyal friend of the show, you can buy a t-shirt that proudly declares your allegiance. And if you still need convincing, you know who you are, then you can buy a not a friend of the show version as well. So you can make your point with a t-shirt or a hoodie.
有圣徒马克杯。这太棒了。也许你是个埃塞尔斯坦的粉丝。你也得到了照顾。有很多埃塞尔斯坦相关的周边。所以这绝对超越了一份梦想中的礼物，不是吗？各位，汤姆，人们从来没有过过这么好的日子。事实上，如果你是俱乐部
It is the perfect icebreaker at parties. What's this you say? You don't know the rest is history. Well, let me tell you, and you will have the perfect shirt while you talk to people about General Gordon or pigeons or the Kaiser or whatever it might be. So the possibilities are endless. And Dominic, there's lots more.
会员，会员通讯里会有一个专属的折扣码。如果你在12月1日之前下单，就能拿到这个惊人的折扣，一切都会完美无比。所以基本上，这将是有史以来最棒的一个圣诞节。所以你需要做的就是前往 www.goalhanger.shop，抢购你的《历史的歇息》装备，并确保在12月1日之前下单。
There are sacral mugs. So that's brilliant. And maybe you're an Athelstan. You are catered for as well. Lots of Athelstan stuff. So truly it's beyond a dream gift, isn't it? People, Tom, have never had it so good. And in fact, if you're a club
有圣骨马克杯。所以这太棒了。也许你是个埃塞尔斯坦。你也得到了照顾。有很多埃塞尔斯坦的周边。所以这真是一个超越梦想的礼物，不是吗？人们，汤姆，从来没有过这么好的日子。事实上，如果你是一个俱乐部
member, there is a special discount code that will come in the newsletter for members. And if you order before the 1st of December, then you'll get this amazing discount and everything would be brilliant. So basically this is going to be the best Christmas ever. So what you need to do is head over to www.goalhanger.shop, grab your rest of this history gear and make sure you order before the 1st of December.
会员，会员通讯中将会提供一个专属折扣码。如果在12月1日之前下单，您将获得这个惊人的折扣，一切都会变得非常棒。所以基本上这将是有史以来最好的圣诞节。您需要做的是前往 www.goalhanger.shop，抢购您的“Rest Is History”周边商品，并确保在12月1日之前下单。
If you're a club member to get that discount. Yeah. If you want to outdo your friends, especially people who listen to other Goalhanger podcasts like The Rest is Politics, this is absolutely the way to do it. So remember to head to www.goalhanger.shop to get your merch. And remember, club members order before the 1st of December to take advantage of that exclusive discount. And we'll be sharing on social media our favourite pictures of you in your Restless History merch,
如果你是俱乐部会员，就可以享受那个折扣。是的。如果你想胜过你的朋友，特别是那些收听其他 Goalhanger 播客（比如《The Rest is Politics》）的人，这绝对是最好的办法。所以请记住前往 www.goalhanger.shop 购买你的周边商品。还要记住，俱乐部会员请在 12 月 1 日之前下单，以享受独家折扣。我们将在社交媒体上分享我们最喜欢的你穿着《Restless History》周边照片，
so send these in over Christmas morning. And remember that is www.goalhanger.shop. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
所以请在圣诞节早上发送这些照片。再次提醒网址是 www.goalhanger.shop。本集暂无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。